if you constantly try to you know to
reach perfection and everything you're
not going to reach it but you're going
to get close if all I ever did was win
or lose at a game I don't really look at
my life as a lot of significant he's a
professional baseball outfielder playing
for the New York Mets
he's a former professional American
football player who played three seasons
in the NFL he was selected by the Denver
Broncos
in the first round of the 2010 NFL Draft
he's Tim Tebow and here's my take on its
top ten rules for success rule number
nine is my personal favorite and I'd
love to know which one you guys like the
best and as always you're watching if
you hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it in the comments
below put quotes around it to other
people can be inspired as well and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick with you as well
enjoy
[Music]
while baseball when I was four or five
six years old it was my first love the
first thing I fell in love with and I
thought most of my life I thought that I
was going to pursue baseball as a
profession second hardest decision in my
life we're sitting on the edge of my bed
crying over it deciding what I was going
to do and I ended up choosing football
and I don't regret that but I do believe
in pursuing passions and what's on your
heart and this is something I'm
passionate about we'll just say about
you that you're even given the
opportunity as a 29 year old man who had
played baseball in a decade there are
certain things in life that we love and
we have chances to pursue them but a lot
of time the fear of the unknown the fear
of failure gets in the way I don't want
that fear to creep in I want the unknown
to creep in I want to be someone that I
pursue whatever is on my heart with
everything that has and if I fall flat
on my face and guess what I'm going to
get right back up I'll read that you're
a force I've read that you're a joke
I've read that you're an embarrassment
not only to yourself but to the game of
baseball the first thing is I'm so
thankful that I don't have to read it I
don't have to listen to it I don't have
to live the roller coaster that the rest
of the world lives of my life I don't
care what they write about me they've
written a lot of things over the last 15
years about me some good some not good
some just because they want to sell
papers I don't necessarily care at the
end of the day I want to pursue my
passion because I believe when you're
pursuing what's on your heart when
you're pursuing what you're convicted by
then I don't have to live with regret 10
15 20 years from now looking back saying
what if what if I would have tried that
worth the success is if I give my all to
it if I get to live out that dream every
single day whether that's in single a
double a triple a worth in the big
leagues you know because joy doesn't
come from success joy comes from knowing
your design and being able to pursue
that every single day and knowing that
I get to live out a dream
[Music]
[Applause]
do you
when solar washes me do something I say
that's how it's supposed to be done and
that's how we have to teach it just like
that because if you do something the
level of success like that then that's
going to carry over to every aspect of
your life if you constantly try to you
know to reach perfection and everything
you're not going to reach it but you're
going to get close and that means you're
going to get close to excellence and
that's what we're always striving for
[Music]
what you want to demo so you can look at
50 beau he's going to have to spark this
augment he goes give a run football team
I got a little motion
you know now I don't watch TV too much
and you know Tariq is most kind of watch
a lot of USD n but not anymore and you
know just be honesty you know try to
stay focused and stay focused and set
little goals for myself every day get a
little bit better learn one new thing
improve in one way every day when I step
by here and when you set all those
little goals and you keep hitting them
then you're constantly going to keep
getting better and and you know not
worry about everything else just let
that take care of itself and worry about
what I can control
[Music]
this is better than any deal great Jule
I think for me and playing sports it's
not being focused on winning or losing a
game because yeah you want to be the
best you want to try to win subin's or
make it to the big leagues and all these
things but you want to at the end of the
day be more than just a sport you're
trying to play you want to dance in that
sport if all you do if all I ever did
was win or lose at a game I don't really
look at my life as a lot of significance
but if I can transcend that sport to
inspire people to put a smile on
people's faces to encourage people to
make a difference to change one person's
life or a million people's life then I
would consider that significance and
meaning the goal is not to be famous the
goal is not to have money in your bank
account the goal not to have what the
world defines the success the goal is to
change life
[Music]
when you believe in yourself that you're
doing the right thing and you're giving
it your all you have to block out the
criticism you have to block out the
naysayers and a lot of times people will
say you know we'll let it go in one ear
and out the other and I just think don't
even let it go in one here don't even
listen to it don't even go on social
media don't read it
don't you know watch the TV and for me
it was just you know stay focused on
what your goal is and don't let the
naysayers sway you from your goal
[Applause]
quarterback permeate yelling when a door
opens that's exciting the door closes
you look for the next one and handle
that every opportunity as best you can
and you treasure the opportunities when
you have them and when they close then
you look forward to the next thing and
you stay patient but you stay passionate
about whatever it is that your dream is
and and you can score it and continue to
be your best bet anything you set your
mind to
[Applause]
[Music]
why priorities in life are number one my
faith in God number two my family in my
relationships with my family
number three is academics and number
four is football
if those you jumble around and you get
the wrong one first and you can have a
lot of problems for me you know trying
to stay grounded you know that's the
best way to do is have your priorities
and try to live by them
she walked with Carrie
he was gonna fight helping liaison if he
go
Oh
I wanted to stay in our hearts and keep
hurting because this will motivate me
personally and I think believe everybody
else coaches and the rest of the players
to never let something like this happen
again
especially we feel we're better than a
team in don't play up to our ability and
I just want to say one thing to the fans
and everybody in Gator Nation um I'm
sorry
extremely sorry you know we're open for
an undefeated season that was my goal
Sutton floors never done here but I
promise you one thing a lot of good will
come out of this you have never seen any
player in the entire country play as
hard as I will play the rest of the
season and you never see someone push
the rest of team as hard as I would push
everybody the rest of the season
you never see a team play harder than we
will the rest of this season god bless
never executor people will strike you
are created by a mediocre God weren't
created to be mediocre you created for
good works which he planned beforehand
you were created to do amazing things
and sometimes we just got to realize our
potential we got to realize that we're
created by also gods your friends do
amazing things and sometimes we just
have the confidence that we were created
to do something special then go do
something special but you have to
believe in yourself you have to believe
that your gift is for such a time as
this you have to believe that you have
the talent you have to believe that you
can make a choice every single day to
wake up the love it and be tastin God a
sacrifice
[Music]
as a football player and that's an
athlete I'm someone who goes extremely
hard and so I need this train extremely
hard and constantly keep going I don't
want a lot of rest because I want to be
able to go go go in the games and when
other teams and other players get tired
I want to be able to be at my peak and
keep going and so this is a workout
where you're going to put your body and
their fatigue but you're going to be
able to keep feeling and a lot how I
play
he loves to train hard so harder is
working out is it elevates him do the
workout as a team at the player I like
being able to wear people down where I
feel like I have an advantage in the
fourth quarter and then the second
happens and that's something how how I
like the train is to be able to feel
like you know I have an edge and I feel
like that is my edge and so I like to
train that way you know whatever you're
doing put everything into it put your
whole heart into and you're going to get
something out of it so if you really
want to become your best push yourself
and whatever you're doing as hard as you
possibly can and you will find results
it's not always about to work out it's
about the work ethic and then we have
the work ethic then you can find the
right workout to fit your body and fit
what you're trying to accomplish
[Music]
[Applause]
but
he didn't miss whatever
is
arrived
my philosophy since I was a little boy
is hard work beats talent when talent
doesn't work is hard I think the biggest
example is how I go about living every
day and honestly practicing and when
people say why do you practice so hard
why do you run every sprint so hard you
don't have to do it you're in good
enough shape well it's not just because
I'm doing it to get in better shape or
I'm doing it to be a leader now I'm
doing it because everything I do I want
to you know set the mark that this is
how you know I do it because I do all
things for the glory of God I do
everything as hard as I can because I do
want to set a good example because I do
want to be a good leader because I do
want to be in shape because I do want to
be the hardest worker but more than
anything because when I do something I
want to be the best that I possibly can
at it very many members arrived upon
line
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Hector Sanchez
asked me to also if you want to nominate
someone for the next top 10 video please
check the description for a link to a
video where you can vote for people and
put in your suggestions as well I'd love
to know what did you take from this
video what was the most important lesson
that you learned that blew your mind
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow
please leave it down the comments below
I'm super curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to Mike
Markham from restaurant HR calm Mike
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word I really
appreciate the support and I hope you're
enjoying the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
of CSUN
think with whoever you are you can at
least respect that I have an opinion on
it and that I believe in something and
I'm going to stand up for what I believe
and so that's something that I'm taking
pride in is that I'm standing up for
what I believe in and I'm so a
conviction about something and for me
that's big
most people don't wake up every single
day excited to take on life excited to
take on the challenges and ready and
able for whatever life throws at them
now what they have to have a copy and
you know I've got to figure it out for
it I'm getting excited are you actually
passionate about what you do and you
willing to sacrifice for it are you
really excited about it you really love
it do you really love it because I'll
tell you this if you do you will have
such an itch because people will want to
be around you why cuz not many people
look like that
there's just how many people live like
that we're not really many data making
people that wake up every single day and
they may have loved life I'm passionate
that I'm ready to take it on I'm going
to sacrifice for it you get that a lot
but you can be that person do you know
why because it's not again it's a choice
that's a choice you wake up every day
you can say I am today I'm waking up to
get better I'm not waking up to get by
today I'm waking up because I love it
I'm excited about I'm passionate about
it I'm willing to sacrifice today I'm
going to go all-in today the way that I
have to train for baseball is different
than I did for so many years for
football and taking 11 12 years off of
baseball I definitely had that off of
baseball and playing football definitely
have to play a little bit of catch-up
but it's also fun when I'm getting to
live out to dreams I think we all think
if you're if you're not a certain age
that you have to give up on certain
dreams or you can't try something new or
change your direction that's another
great lesson absolutely and then also a
thing is people do
do something based on the chances they
have a succeeding witness since when
were dreams based on the chances dreams
are based on something that's placed in
your heart
based on the chances of succeeding it